hello everyone and welcome back to the
grand chester it's around 16 of the
Blitz section 11 our genome versus
magnus carlsen and it's quite a roller
coaster of the game so I do hope you
enjoy it without further ado let's just
check it out so 11 with the white pieces
opens with c4 and it will be very
interesting to see how eleven bounces
back well or if he bounces back after
that Roxy to brilliancy by Magnus in the
previous game that we've shown so the
English opening is on the board we have
g6 by Magnus Knight c3 sorry about that
we have c5 by Magnus g3 Bishop to g7 and
Bishop to g2 Knight to c6 we have the
ultra symmetrical variation b3 Magnus
again that goes with the symmetry we
have d6 Queen to d2 and now Magnus
breaks symmetry with a 5 we have B 3:11
prepares to finca to the dark square
Bishop Knight G to e7 also perhaps
possible to develop the knight to f6 but
this way after you Castle you maybe have
ideas of pushing at 5 also after the
bishop is developed the e6 denied from a
7 Eisley controls the d5 square if you
might you know consider pushing d5 so
Bishop to b5 and now Bishop to e6 so not
allowing black any d5 IDs 11 goes in
Knight to d5 now with the the Queen d7
by Magnus developing the Queen now after
the King castles the rooks will be
nicely connected and also Magnus is
waiting for 11 to develop the knight so
he can trade over the light square
bishop so with Bishop to h3 with III by
11 and now Magnus castles knights to e -
now the knight no longer controls the f3
and h3 squares so Bishop to h3 and there
is one game that reached this position
that where castle was played and
interestingly it's a game between a I
believe at 2100 and a 2300 player so
instead of casting with Bishop captures
on h3 and it is as of move 12th that we
have a completely new game so Magnus
trades Queen captures on h3 and now
Knight eat the c3 support
the night here so if Magnus decides to
trade the other night can take the place
of this night on b5 and also supports
the be 5 square in case black wants the
bust open which would be 5 as it is well
most likely white will Castle queenside
so ro k b8 the Magnus has ideas of a 6
and B 5 with queenside castle and now
without wasting time to play a six
Magnus just eliminates the d5 Knight so
now asking do you want to mess up your
pawn structure would see characters on
b5 then I can go Knights the b4 which
will threaten both of the the d5 on NDA
to pawn or do you want to play a night
cap for Sundy 5 which Levin does but now
the b v square is available so pawn to
b5 and it's basically a race Magnus
calls Magnus will attack on the Queen
side 11 will attack on the King side and
the Magnus already has a breakthrough
with b5 with f4 by 11 and then now a5 by
Magnus so both players just completely
ignore what the other guy is doing rook
h2 f1 with a 4 by Magnus and now f5
which is very often when you have
castles of opposite sides you know if
you're a very long time most of the
times you will have players blocking
that they're not interested in in what
happens on the other side of the board
well maybe not on the highest level but
on some lower levels but ok 8 capture
some beats 3 by Magnus now you can no
longer ignore this so it captures on b3
we have be captured on c4 big captors
and c4 ending out rook the b3 a very
nice rook lived by Magnus now prepares
to bring the other look over to b8 with
f6 grabbing even more space so it's not
really a problem since
Carlsen's the bishop will do wonders on
h6 to look at it and nicely lined up on
the diagonal were 11th king and queen
are so king to see - you need to unpin
as soon as possible also this comes with
tempo but now rook F to b8
just the doubling up here threatening
rook out for some BT which would just
win the game so Bishop to c3 and here
you have to decide what to do there are
a lot of very interesting ideas here
sorry about that I just have to
someone's at the door
well sorry about that
so Bishop to c3 and like I said there
are a lot of very interesting ideas here
you could well maybe just the gobble of
the bishop which is quite interesting
rook captures on c3 the problem is well
the problem is only if you have
something like Knight captures on c3 if
Knight captures on c3 then you have
Knight the d4 check and it's game over
because if you capture you lose the
Queen and the only other option you have
is team to c1 but now Knight b3 trick
just picks up the Queen so it kind of
works but not really because after rook
captures on c3 you have King captures on
c3 and now okay you still have 94 Wyatt
is unable to capture the knight
threatens the rook the b3 mate but white
defends with rook the b1 so not not a
possibility since the black doesn't have
a good way of continuing the attack so
here Magnus says and it's something you
should always ask yourselves when you're
well leading an attack which one of my
pieces is doing nothing so here the
Queen on h3 is doing pretty much nothing
so not going to decides to bring the
Queen into the attack as well Queen back
to d7 now he wants to go to b8 and to
have a cerebral triple or artillery on
on the B file and 11 goes rook to a1 so
what do you do here how do you continue
this attack feel free to pause the video
and continue the attack for Magnus while
I give you a couple of seconds so for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations on paying attention so
far and for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show it's night the d4
check now the problem is you have to
capture the night if you don't capture
the night then everything just goes
wrong it for example if you move the
King King c1
now the rooks are disconnected and here
Magnus says Queen to a4 which is just
wonderful stuff and you don't really you
don't really have a good way of playing
this position anymore if you capture the
Queen then rook the b1 is mate in one
there's no other way around it and even
if you don't if you try something like
butter of characters here to clear maybe
de 2 square by eliminating the night
still you get sick after sandy 4 and the
same threats are there if you try to
escape with the King just
to be one a double check from the Queen
and the rook and after you move you you
lose this row of characters characters
and you end this variation being down a
whole rook
so after night the d4 check 11 had to
capture it and we have C captures on d4
again you don't really have any options
of pushing the pawn or capturing because
of this nice bishop on h6 and it's
interesting that 11 actually forces the
bishop to h6 by playing f6 so really
really unfortunate for him we looked at
a 2 now you have to prevent rook to be 2
this way but now Queen to b7 now
bringing the Queen into the attack
finally and here there well if you try
to escape late the King D 1 you get the
Bishop captures on e3 you just move the
Queen so after Knight character so you
get the D capture screen captures now
rugby one check just win the material
because after you move King E - you're
gonna play rook captures on f1 and out
you're down the road so you will just
capture it Queen to be one Czech picks
up the rook on a two as well so a very
unpleasant position for 11 he played the
Queen to c1 but here Magnus just finds a
brilliant breakthrough he and this is
one of the well one of the reasons 11
himself says that it's sometimes helpful
for him to play bug house just for real
chess because you have to imagine where
where certain pieces should be so here
if you imagine the Queen on b3 that's
that's pretty deadly so here what Magnus
does is he just clears the room for the
Queen
he plays rook the c3 gives up the rook
and now he has Queen to b3 check so
Knight captures on c3 Queen to b3 with
check and here 11 played King to d2 as
it is the only move he has available to
him but it was also in this position
that 11 resigned the game animal 29 as
there is nothing more to do here so here
you could just play a bunch of
characters and III check you win the
Queen so that's one way to do it but you
don't even have to do you can just play
pawn captures night with check now if
you capture with the Queen then Bishop
captures on e3 check the flags the King
and then you just pick up the Queen or
you move the king then you lose the rook
captures with check
now your upper piece and of course you
are in a completely winning position so
after King D 211 our intern resigns the
game and yet another brilliant victory
for Magnus Carlsen who who is uh just
you know it being incredible this
tournament sure that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank Stephen green for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here think of for
watching and I will see you soon with at
least one more game from this tournament
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and preparing our next big
saga thank you I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day